the rumor is
um that somebody not kim kardashian
wrote her monologue that it wasn't
penned by kim but in fact a writing team
was assembled to write those jokes for
her is this true or false i have no idea
okay i don't know i have no insight into
it whatsoever are you sure you didn't
sign an nda i didn't sign an nda i
didn't i didn't some of those jokes i
wish i wrote they were great jokes you
watched the whole moment i watched the
whole monologue she
actually yeah again delivered them well
she did deliver them cleanly but you
would have to agree
she could have paused it was a little
she was a little ahead of it i liked
that she didn't pause
i liked that she bit the end of the
laugh
because usually when you have something
like a politician or somebody go up
there has never done stand-up they just
wait and then it's a restart every
single time she was able to build some
momentum because she was catching i i
think she could have
increased the pleasure from the audience
by 30 percent she didn't even it was one
of these things like what the [ __ ] is
happening [ __ ] the audience like what is
happening this is so good and by the end
of it you're like i think she this lady
just did 14 perfect jokes in a row i
think she really doesn't give a [ __ ]
about snl
she i think you know what i mean like
yeah i think at the last joke she's
never seen another monologue before
she's never seen it she's yeah this is
good enough yeah what do i do i just go
i say before i [ __ ] on my entire family
in existence yeah let's go oh wait when
i talk guys laugh yeah
yeah i i i remember this
from the from the 2000s before i met
kanye yeah did you write on it i had
nothing to do with it because a buddy of
mine i told you hit me up and he was
like i saw neil chris rock and blake
griffin
at the mercer having lunch yeah we were
someone who was working we were trying
to help kim kardashian like guys
those are the three i would choose
blake griffin
what a look that is for blake griffin to
be like they got the best writers
they're the best in the country they got
chris rock and of course he got blake
yeah yeah uh
yeah no good for him he and then they
were in the sketch and so i don't think
uh i have no idea who wrote it and then
somebody told me like i think schumer
wrote it and seth rogen somehow was
involved i have no idea no but i
i think
the uh
i think the uh
keep the jokes
keep them you know what's funny though
is like going back to the kim k
monologue uh which was exceptional is
that there were trans jokes in it i
guess one trans joke or something uh
a caitlyn yeah maybe it was a caitlyn
joke yeah and it was like and she has
the authority to make the joke even
though she's not part of the community
because of proximity to the community
like nobody said anything nobody asked
caitlyn if it was okay right but because
of her perceived proximity like nobody
knows if like she hates [ __ ] trans
people but they're like no it's her mom
dad so she's allowed to make the jokes
is she
uh well that's ex dave's argument was
like yo i had a friend right right so
she's like i got a mom dad right so does
that allow her to do the joke
um
like it looks like she's gotten away
with it
nobody said a single thing now it was
sweet and it was kind of cute and dave's
stuff seemed like it was like this is
how i feel right and here's a joke that
goes along with it seemed a bit pointed
yeah it seemed i i actually feel like if
it was less um
uh
yeah yeah it was less like if he cared
less about like making the point it was
almost like comedy was a tool to drive
home the actual point instead of like
here's a random joke about trans people
here's a random joke about parks yeah i
think kim was in some ways just saying
words yeah
well yeah like just like words words
words words words words
[Laughter]
my husband has bad personality all right
yeah i hope kanye makes a diss song
about her because it's like way worse
than anything
any snl has done did you notice though
that like she made sure to say the
things that he
really cares about yeah
he's the richest black man in america
which is not even true
uh who is
another guy oh
no no
no bob johnson the guy johnson yeah
probably yeah there's like a few other
but uh but still like she said all the
things they were doing yeah she knew
like you can say this if you also say my
personality [ __ ] as long as you say i'm
really rich yeah and i'm a genius yeah
and i just said greatest rappers best
rapper of all time and all of us were
like yeah
uh he's not the best i would argue
he is not the best
rhymer of all time but he is the best
hip-hop musician all in
of all time that's fair yeah i like that
take if you're including producing the
music yeah of course
meeting with who who else
j dilla yeah like there's a few people
yeah timberland and and pharrell dr dre
doctor like i said those guys that
didn't write there are guys that did i
mean for all rights a little bit but
like yeah but didn't really don't have
their don't have many of their own out
yeah he's amazing but that guy's kanye's
[ __ ] unbelievable as a musician yeah
unbelievable yeah
[Applause]